alors direction maintenant la musique
merci à tous les trois de nous avoir
rejoint donc vous êtes membres du groupe
euh voilà ça y est que j'ai mais si la
danse du chien on arê on a pas arrêé
d'en parler la danse du chien pourquo ça
s'appelle comme ça oui parce que moi
depuis le début du 78 j'attends la
réponse à la question c'est tellement
atypique que finalement j'avais du mal à
à retrouver euh dans le bon ordre le le
nom de votre groupe euh Sébastien
peut-être vous êtes vous le guitariste
du groupe peut-être racontez-nous
l'histoire de de ce nom de cette
formation je pense que éric est plus é
vous êtes chanteur alors est-ce que vous
avoyez Éric oui ça m'arrive absolument
ce matin encore d'ailleurs je en fait ça
commençait dans les petits clubs où on
jouit à l'époque on avait pas encore de
nom très peu de morceaux et en fait un
soir il y a voilà il y a un chien dans
le public qui enfin qui appartenait une
des personnes qui était dans le public
qui s'est mise sur ses petites PES
arrière comme ça et puis on a dit voilà
c'était la danse du chien en parlant du
morceau qu'on venait de jouer les gens
ont cru que c'était le nom du du groupe
voilà c'est resté et puis mais c'est
aussi une référence peut-être à vos
textes aussi après voilà et après on
s'est dit que ça pouvait avoir
effectivement un une signification par
rapport à oui au au textees enfin ce
qu'on raconte dans les morceaux en fait
qui sont des histoires un peu un peu en
marge avec des gens qui ont une vie de
chien et qui euh voilà qui sont un peu à
la rame quotidienne VO donc la dance du
chien en fait ça peut illustrer le fait
que les gens en fait quand ils sont un
peu dans la mouise ils ont tendance à à
avoir très envie de faire la fête de la
musique à de danser voir C ex en fa
c'est ça alors comment on peut allez
Paul je m'adresse à vous comment on peut
vous êtes le batteur gr pas comment on
peut définir votre style est-ce que vous
avez tous les trois donc vous êtes CIN
en tout mais est-ce que vous avez tous
les trois déjà là sur ce plateau les
mêmes la même culture musicale les mêmes
horizons comment non on n pas la même
culture les de Bour qui sont en face de
moi beaucoup plus cultivé que nous en
fait d'abord je suis beaucoup plus
cultivé queeux mais bon je pense que ça
se voit naturellement et donc eux ils
viennent plutôt du du du du rock
indépendant hm hm et euh et nous enfin
nous le saxophoniste et le
contrebassiste on vient plutôt du jazz
en fait c'est une espèce de rencontre
comme ça de gens qui font du jazz mais
qui avaient pas envie de faire que ça et
euh de du rock 1D qui avait envie
d'ouvrir sa musique à autre chose donc
voilà c'est une espèce de rencontre
entre deux cultures c'est à la fois donc
rock jazz blues tout ça ça fait de la
musique alternative finalement par que
tu es un peu indépendant libre et cetera
bah écout je vous propose qu'on regarde
un extrait d'un de vos clips pour avoir
le le temps
[Musique]
exactement
pu
[Musique]
tambunuu
tambunu
[Musique]
Erric vous êtes donc l'auteur de de ces
titres vous chantez en anglais on a pu
le on a pu s'en apercevoir pourquoi ce
choix pourquoi la langue anglaise bah
l'anglais parce que en fait la langue
dans le champ c'est un peu comme si on
choisissait son instrument et en
l'occurrence l'anglais ça sonne vraiment
bien sur la musique qu'on fait qui a
plutôt d'influence c'est pour des
raisons de sonorité angaxonne ouais
c'est comme si j'avais avais choisi la
de de chanter de la guitare électrique
plutôt que de l'accordéon quoi c'est ça
sonne pas de la même façon quoi al
j'adore l'accordéon j'adore la chanson
française fait très bien mais j'adore
des gens comme Bachou évidemment
ginbourg Nougaro et compagnie mais je
ouais dans GRP sentiez pas non plus très
à l'aise avec alors il y a un petit peu
de feignantisme parce que c'est vrai
qu'avec l'anglais on arrive quand même à
à sortir un texte qui sonne plus
facilement ça c'est faut palmier mais
non non je je m'interdis pas d'un jour
de de chanter en français mais avec un
autre groupe mais là je reviens sur
l'extrait qu'on a vu moi je vois pas
trop le la couleur jazz dans l'extrait
bah là en l'occurrence celui-là il est
pas très libre au niveau de la facture
jazz mais il est très influencé par
ouais du jazz africain à la F ou VO
c'est très ternaire qu'on voit assez peu
ou notamment qui vit du rock 1 D voilà
c'est pas dans le rock c'est plutôt ce
qu'on appelle binaire et là c'est très
ternaire y a des morceaux où il y a
beaucoup de rock peu jazz et d'autres
c'est beaucoup de jazz et de rock le
mélange est différent à chaque fois de
toute façon alors on peut rappeler vous
avez déjà sorti deux albums un en 2004
un en 2009 et quels sont vos vos projets
à venir un autre album alors il y a
c'est plutôt des EP pour l'instant il y
aura un EP de de de compo et un EP de de
plutôt de reprises qu'on aime bien faire
qu'on fait sur scène souventjà deux
qu'on fait sur scène et euh et voilà
qu'on trouvait sympa à faire parce que
les gens aiment bien et nous aussi c'est
vrai que vous êtes un groupe qu'on
dirait plus live hein plus que ouais oua
ouis carrément ouais a écoué studio avec
d'ailleurs on voit bien sur les images
vous aimez bien bouger ça bouge he on
sent que c'est
VI merveilleux merveilleux danseurs ben
voilà qui était là compagnie CFB
451 on travaille aussi avec une danseuse
s'appelle Andrea cur voilà une très
grande danseuse allemande là qui va on
devrait être programmé pour 2014 en
novembre 2014 à chot avec elle voilà sur
sur des impros sur son spectacleelle qui
va durer 5 jours s'appelle rock and roll
suicide et sur la dernière soirée où on
présentera un concert donc parce que
vous avez plusieurs dates là sur un
petit peu toute la France bahà cet été
on tourne beaucoup dans le sud et puis
sud sud-ouest et puis ouais on a une
quoi une quinzaine oui c'est ça B
peut-être qu'on peut directement se
rendre sur votre site internet
VO on va perdre beaucoup de temps là
si en tout cas merci beaucoup d'être
venue PL merci merci à la danse du chien
j'aime vraiment bien le titre ah ouais
c'est bien parce que ça accroche
forcément c'est c'est très accrocheur
allez or on finit cette chronique
culture avec l'agend date voilà une date
et on continue dans le cinéma exactement
pour la soirée de clôture de la verrière
fait son cinéma donc pour rappel c'était
une c'est une manifestation autour de
l'audiovisuel qui s'achève donc ce
vendredi le 29 juin à 19h30 au scarabé
et donc l'ensemble des vidéos des
personnes qui ont participé à ce
concours seront donc diffusé en présence
donc des vidéastes amateurs et trois
prix seront remis ce jour-là